WELCOME --
TO WHAT IS THE ASSEMBLY LABOR
COMMITTEE AND ALSO JOINT --
HEARING OF THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY OF LABOR COMMITTEES I'M
HONORED.
THAT MY COLLEAGUE HERE THE CHAIR
OF SENATE LABOR AND TODAY WILL
HAVE A SPECIAL HEARING.
ON A MATTER THAT WILL BE BEFORE
THE BALLOT BEFORE WE BEGIN.
I'D LIKE TO OFFER OUR MY CO
CHAIR AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A
FEW REMARKS.
THANK YOU.
GREAT TO BE HERE AND LET'S GET
THE BALL ROLLING ASSIDUOUS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ALWAYS --
ON TOP OF IT AND LET'S GET RIGHT
TO IT --
BILL SAID OTHERS CALL OUR FIRST
WITNESS TODAY --
THIS IS -- A
HEARING --
FOCUSED ON ISSUES RELATED --
TO AMBULANCE EMPLOYEES AND THEIR
BREAKS -- WE
HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
LEOS OFFICE.
CHAS ALAMO WHO IS PREPARED TO
PROVIDE US WITH AN OVERVIEW.
OF THE INITIATIVE AS PROPOSED
WELL WELCOME AND WE ARE READY
WHEN YOU ARE.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTERS CHAIRS --
I'M JAZZ ALMA WITH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE --
AS WAS SAID WE RATS TO PROVIDE A
VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THIS
INITIATIVE.
ARM AND AND WE COULD PUT
TOGETHER A HANDOUT THAT YOU
SHOULD HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU THAT
THAT THIS TESTIMONY WILL BE
WORKING OFF OF BEFORE GETTING
INTO THE HAND OUT SPECIFICALLY
STE A BIT.
OUR OFFICE HAS A BIT OF A
DIFFERENT ROLE WHEN IT COMES TO
INITIATIVES --
IT'S UNLIKE ARE SORT OF POLICY
AND BUDGET ROLE WHERE WE PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE LIKE I'M
WITH THE INITIATIVE PROCESS WERE
TASKED MORE IS AN IMPARTIAL
THIRD PARTY.
WE REVIEW THE INITIATIVE ASSESS
WHAT IT'S FISCAL AFFECT WOULD BE
FOR STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
BUT DON'T MAKE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS OR PINE ON THE
MERITS OF THE INITIATIVES --
SO IF WE TURN TO PAGE ONE WITH
THAT CONTEXT IN MIND.
OUR ROLE AS AN OFFICE IS.
TO EVALUATE EVERY INITIATIVE
THAT SUBMITTED OUR ALONGSIDE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THAT
EVALUATION --
GOES ALONG WITH THE PETITIONS
THAT HOG GO OUT BEFORE
REGISTERED VOTERS DURING THE
SIGNATURE GATHERING PROCESS
MONTHS INTO AN INITIATIVE HAS
GATHERED ENOUGH SIGNATURES TO
QUALIFY. FOR FOR THE BALLOT ARE
OFFICE AGAIN REVIEWS AND
INITIATIVE PROVIDES A BACKGROUND --
EVALUATES WHAT THE INITIATIVE
DOES AND ASSESSES ITS FISCAL
IMPACTS ON WERE CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF DOING THAT RIGHT NOW
FOR THIS INITIATIVE FOR THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT --
TURNING TO PAGE TWO THIS HANDOUT
BEGINS WITH THE BACKGROUND
SECTION.
DESCRIBES THE PROPOSAL ITSELF
AND DISCUSSES THE PHYSICAL
EFFECTS OF MEASURE ON AS YOU
KNOW IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR AMBULANCES ARE DISPATCHED TO
LOCATION OF A NINE ONE ONE
EMERGENCY CALL TYPICALLY AN
AMBULANCE HAS A TWO PERSON CREW
WITH AN EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TECHNICIAN OR EMT AND A
PARAMEDIC.
THEY PROVIDE MEDICAL TREATMENT
AND THEN TRANSPORT THE PATIENT
TO THE HOSPITAL --
IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT THREE
QUARTERS OF EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION ARE PROVIDED BY
FOR PROFIT AMBULANCE COMPANIES
ON THE REMAINING QUARTER
TYPICALLY IS AN AMBULANCE IT'S
OPERATED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTAL
AGENCY --
AND TO ENSURE THAT AMBULANCE
TRANSPORTATION IS AVAILABLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE COUNTIES
COORDINATE THE SYSTEMS OF
EMERGENCY MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION.
IN A COORDINATED SYSTEM BY
CENTRALLY IN THEIR IN THEIR
COUNTY REGION SEPARATING THE
COUNTY INTO ZONES AND IN EACH
ZONE THE COUNTY.
THROUGH A COMPETITIVE BIDDING
PROCESS SELECTS A PRIMARY
AMBULANCE COMPANY PRIMARY
AMBULANCE PROVIDER TO SERVE THAT
AREA.
AND THIS IS SORT OF A A
CONTRACTUAL EXCHANGE BETWEEN THE
COUNTY AND THE AMBULANCE
PROVIDER.
ARE ON THE ONE HAND THE COUNTY
KNOWS THAT AMBULANCE SERVICES
WILL BE AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT
THAT REGION.
AND IT ALSO ENSURES THAT MOST
AND HARD SERVICES ARE PROVIDED
WITH IN AT A CERTAIN TIME LIMIT
SO THERE'S THERE'S A TIME
REQUIREMENT ON ON NINE ONE ONE
BECAUSE THE AMBULANCE HAS TO GET
TO THIS TEAM'S TYPICALLY WITHIN.
EIGHT TO TWELVE MINUTES AN ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS
CONTRACTUAL CHANGE FOR THE
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS THIS SORT OF
A GUARANTEED INSURER REVENUE
STREAM BECAUSE THEY'RE GONNA BE
RESPONDING TO ALL THE CALLS ON
HIS OWN.
AND THEREFORE ROOM WILL RECEIVE --
BILLING CHARGES FOR ALL THOSE
ALL THOSE TRANSPORTS
[inaudible]
ON IN MOST CASES EITHER
GOVERNMENT PROVIDED OR
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE PAYS FOR
THE COST OF AMBULANCE TRIPS
ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF AMBULANCE
TRIPS ARE FOR PATIENTS WITH
MEDICARE OR MEDICAID HOW.
IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT 20% ARE FOR
PATIENTS WITH COMMERCIAL HEALTH
INSURANCE AND THE REST ARE FOR
PATIENTS WITH WITH NO HEALTH
INSURANCE WHATSOEVER --
TURNING TO PAGE.
THREE DESCRIBE BRIEFLY SOME OF
WHAT A TYPICAL AMBULANCE TRIP
COSTS IN CALIFORNIA WE THINK
THAT'S ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS ON AVERAGE PER TRIP --
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID HOW --
ARE BUILD A SOMEWHAT LESS THAN
THAT AMOUNT THERE REIMBURSEMENT
FOR AMULETS PROVIDERS IS LOWER
THAN THE AVERAGE COST OF AN
AMBULANCE TRIP IN THE STATE.
SO TO MAKE UP FOR THESE LOSSES A
PRIVATE AMBULANCE COMPANIES
ACTUALLY BILL COMMERCIAL HEALTH
INSURERS MUCH MORE THAN THE
AVERAGE COSTS ARM UP TO ABOUT
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
TRIP ON AVERAGE --
FOR FOR THESE SERVICES AND IN
THIS WAY AMBULANCE PROVIDERS
BALANCE OUT THERE THEIR PAYER
MAX IN ORDER TO COVER THEIR
COSTS.
I'M TURNING TO THE TOP OF PAGE
FOUR WILL GET INTO EMTS AND
PARAMEDICS THEMSELVES AND THEIR
RESTING MEAL BREAK STRUCTURES.
THEY'RE ABOUT SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
EMTS AND PARAMEDICS CURRENTLY
ACTIVE IN THE STATE.
AND MOST AMBULANCE CREWS ARE
CONSIST OF ONE EMT AND ONE
PARAMEDIC THEY TYPICALLY WORK
TWELVE HOUR SHIFTS THOUGH IN
SOME CASES THEY WORK TWENTY FOUR
HOUR SHIFTS TOGETHER --
AND LIKE MOST OTHER EMPLOYEES --
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS ARE REQUIRED
TO PRIDE BEYOND REST BREAKS TO
THEIR EMTS AND PARAMEDICS.
BUT IN THIS CASE BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF THE THE BUSINESS --
EMTS AND PARAMEDICS HAVE
TRADITIONALLY REMAINED ON CALL
DURING THEIR RESTING MEAL BREAKS
SO THEY MIGHT GO AND TAKE A
SCHEDULED MEAL BREAK.
BUT THE NINE ONE ONE CALL COMES
AND THEY'LL TAKE THAT CALL
RESPOND TO THE CALL AND THEN TRY
TO RESCHEDULE THEIR MEAL BREAK
LATER.
AND AS A RESULT IS OFTEN
DIFFICULT FOR EMTS AND
PARAMEDICS TO SCHEDULE THEIR
PRICKS PROFT INTERRUPTED AND
SOMETIMES THEY WON'T RECEIVE
THEIR THEIR MEAL BREAK DURING
THEIR SHIFT.
THOUGH IT AT THE SAME TIME MOST
EMERGENCY AMBULANCE CREWS HAVE
SUFFICIENT WORK SIGNIFICANT
DOWNTIME DURING THEIR SHIFT THEY
ARE THEY'RE POSTED AT THEIR
LOCATION AND AND WAITING FOR A
NINE ONE ONE CALL TO COME AND
BUT MAYBE THERE'S AN HOUR TO IN
BETWEEN CALLS.
SO DURING THESE TIMES THESE
PERIODS OF DOWNTIME CREWS CAN
TYPICALLY TAKE A BREAK.
EVEN THOUGH IT WASN'T MAYBE PRE
SCHEDULED AND THAT IT COULD BE
INTERRUPTED THEY DON'T KNOW FOR
SURE THAT IT WON'T BE
INTERRUPTED --
AND TURNING TO TO THE NEXT PAGE --
THIS LONGSTANDING INDUSTRY
PRACTICE OF HAVING EMTS AND
PARAMEDICS STAY ON CALL DURING
BREAK --
COULD BE AFFECTED BY RECENT
STATE SUPREME COURT DECISION I
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN THE STATE
SUPREME COURT FOUND THAT ON CALL
BREAKS OF THIS NATURE ACTUALLY
VIOLATE STATE LABOR LAW.
AND INSTEAD THE COURT FOUND THAT
EMPLOYERS MUST PROVIDE OFF DUTY
BREAKS THAT ARE UNINTERRUPTIBLE
SO THE CASE WAS A JUSTICE V. AB
AND SECURITY SERVICES.
CHATTED WITH PRIVATE SECURITY
GUARDS THAT WERE REQUIRED AT THE
TIME TO KEEP A WALKIE TALKIE ON
THEM DURING THEIR BREAKS AND THE
COURT FOUND THAT THIS ACTUALLY
VIOLATED STATE LAW.
AND IT DID DID NOT QUALIFY AS A
BREAK BECAUSE THEY WERE ON CALL
[inaudible]
ON THE LABOR LAWS AND WAGE
ORDERS THAT RELATE TO PRIVATE
SECURITY GUARDS ON THE A JUSTICE
CASE ARE PRETTY SIMILAR. TO
THOSE THAT APPLY TO EMTS AND
PARAMEDICS AND AS A RESULT IT
APPEARS LIKELY THAT THE THE
DECISION AND THE AT JUSTICE CASE
WHAT SOME POINT IN THE FUTURE.
BE FOUND TO APPLY TO EMTS AND
PARAMEDICS BY THE STATE'S COURTS --
SO MOVING TO THE NEXT SO THE
PIECE OF BACKGROUND.
ON PAGE.
SIX WE HAVE TO ASSESS.
WHAT THE LIKELY OUTCOME WOULD BE
FOR THE CURRENT --
CURRENT INDUSTRY PRACTICE IF EMT
AND PARAMEDICS ARE PROVIDED OFF
DUTY BREAKS UNDER THIS
EXHAUSTIVE DECISION AND WE SEE
THAT THIS WOULD LIKELY INCREASE
COSTS FOR PRIVATE AMBULANCE
COMPANIES.
ON BECAUSE IN ORDER TO BRING
MEET MEET THE RESPONSE TIME
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE IN THEIR
CONTRACTS WITH COUNTIES --
THEY WOULD HAVE TO LIKELY AT AN
ADDITIONAL AMBULANCE UNIT OR
PERHAPS PERHAPS TO IN SOME AREAS
SO THAT SOME COULD GO ON BREAKS
ESSENTIALLY TURNING THEIR RADIOS
OFF FOR THAT THIRTY MINUTE
PERIOD.
AND THEY WOULD HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL AMBULANCE IN THE AREA
TO RESPOND TO A NINE ONE ONE
CALL THAT WOULD COME DOWN --
STATEWIDE WE THINK THAT THESE
NEW COSTS POTENTIALLY BE IN
EXCESS OF A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND IN RESPONSE TO THESE NEW
COSTS AMBULANCE COMPANIES IN
ORDER TO REMAIN PROFITABLE COULD
MAKE CERTAIN.
COULD RESPOND IN IN A VARIETY OF
WAYS ON WE GOT THEM LISTED HERE
FIRST WE WE THINK THAT SOME
AMBULANCE COMPANIES COULD
NEGOTIATE.
COMPROMISE AGREEMENTS WITH THEIR
LABOR UNIONS ARE WHICH WOULD
SUPERSEDE THE REQUIREMENTS OF A
JUSTICE AND SORT OF BE A MIDDLE
GROUND TO FULL COMPLIANCE AND
THEREFORE.
REDUCE SOME COSTS.
SECONDLY AMBULANCE COMPANIES
COULD ATTEMPT TO BILL COMMERCIAL
INSURERS AT HIGHER AMOUNTS TO
RECRUIT ADDITIONAL REVENUE TO
OFFSET SOME OF THESE COSTS.
MON THIRD AMBULANCE COMPANIES
COULD LOOK FOR WAYS TO REDUCE
THEIR OPERATING COSTS SO FOR
INSTANCE THEY COULD TRY DOING
MORE CASES HAVE AN AMBULANCE
STAFF WITH TO IT EMTS.
SUPPOSED TO AN EMT AND A
PARAMEDIC HIM TEASED WAITERS
ARTS ARE TYPICALLY LOWER THAN
THOSE FOR PARAMEDICS SO THAT
SORT OF OPERATIONAL CHANGE MIGHT
REDUCE SOME OF THEIR COSTS.
A OPERATIONAL CHANGES SUCH AS
THIS WOULD HAVE TO BE
RENEGOTIATED WITH THE COUNTIES
BECAUSE IT WOULD IT WOULD CHANGE
THEIR CONTRACTS --
AND FINALLY.
WE THINK THAT IN MANY INSTANCES
AMBULANCE COMPANIES WILL WILL
SEEK TO RENEGOTIATE THEIR
CONTRACTS WITH THE COUNTY.
I EMERGENCY SERVICES AGENCIES
AND BY RENEGOTIATE I MEAN IN
ORDER TO REMAIN PROFITABLE.
THEY MAY SAY TO A COUNTY.
THAT THEY'RE UNABLE TO CONTINUE
PAYING THE ANNUAL FEE THAT WAS
IN THE ORIGINAL CONTRACT IN THAT
THEY WOULD NEED TO REDUCE THIS
ANNUAL FEE --
IN SOME CASES EVEN THEY MAY NOW
BE ABLE TO MAKE ANY PAYMENTS THE
COUNTY WHATSOEVER AS A RESULT OF
THESE NEW COSTS AND THE COULD IN
THESE CASES.
REQUIRE OR SEEK A SUBSIDY FROM
THE COUNTY TO THE AMBULANCE
PROVIDER IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN
OPERATIONS IN THIS AREA.
ODD GIVEN THE NEW COSTS --
IF YOU TURN TO PAGES SEVEN
MOVEON DEBT TO THIS PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY.
AND IT WOULD.
REQUIRED THAT HE M. TEAS AND
PARAMEDICS REMAIN ON CALL DURING
THEIR ENTIRE WORK SHIFT SO IN
EFFECT IT WOULD BE A
CONTINUATION AND AUTHORIZATION
OF LONGSTANDING INDUSTRY
PRACTICE.
IT WOULD ALSO SEEK.
TO TAKE THIS REQUIREMENT BUT
DANTE AND PARAMEDICS STAY ON
CALL AND APPLY RETROACTIVELY. TO
LEGAL CASES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
IN THE COURTS THAT EMTS AND
PARAMEDICS HAVE BROUGHT AGAINST
PRIVATE AMBULANCE PROVIDERS --
SEEKING.
DAMAGES FOR FOR ALLEGED
VIOLATION OF OF ME ON BREAK LOS.
ADDITIONALLY THE MEASURE WOULD
REQUIRE THE AMBULANCE PROVIDERS
PROVIDE IMPROVED BREAK SCHEDULES
FOR EMTS AND PARAMEDICS AND THAT
THEY IMPLY.
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL TRAINING AND
MAKE AVAILABLE MENTAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES FOR THEIR EMTS AND
PARAMEDICS --
TURNING TO THE THE FINAL PAGE.
WHERE WE ASSESS?
THE LIKELY FISCAL AFFECTS OF THE
INITIATIVE.
THIS MEASURE IS SOMEWHAT COMPLEX
BECAUSE ON THE ONE HAND WE HAVE.
TO ASSESS WHAT WHAT COULD HAPPEN
IN THE IN THE AMBULANCE INDUSTRY
UNDER THE ACOSTA DECISION.
AND COMPARE THAT TO WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN AYE IF VOTERS WERE TO
APPROVE THE MEASURE.
SO BECAUSE THE AUGUSTA'S
DECISION IS LIKELY TO RESULT IN
NEW COSTS FOR AMBULANCE
COMPANIES.
AND THEREFORE NEW COSTS FOR FOR
COUNTY GOVERNMENTS --
A CONTINUATION OF CURRENT
PRACTICE WHICH IS REQUIRED BY
THIS MEASURE WOULD WOULD LIKELY
RESULT.
IN ARE FISCAL BENEFITS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS I IN THE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
AND WE USED THE PHRASE FISCAL
BENEFITS BECAUSE IN SOME CASES
IT COULD BE ADDITIONAL FEE
REVENUE FROM THE COUNTY.
BUT IN OTHER CASES IT COULD BE A
SMALLER SUBSIDY FROM THE COUNTY
TO THE AMBULANCE PROVIDER IT
COULD BE ANSWERED OF EITHER SIDE
THE LEDGER SO WE TURN THAT
FISCAL BENEFITS AGAIN AND IN THE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
ONLY.
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THIS TIME.
I THANK YOU MISTER ALAMO --
WAS ONE THING YOU MENTIONED THAT
THE FOLLOWING --
WHAT WAS RECOMMENDED IN OF THIS
LAW --
AUGUSTA SO COULD.
RESULT IN COST OF HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS I'M JUST CURIOUS.
WHAT WHAT POLICE OFFICERS DO
WHEN THEY WANT A MEAL BREAK I I
DON'T POLICE OFFICERS?
GET TO TAKE A DESIGNATED MIL
BREAK WHETHER OR NOT ON CALL IN
WITNESSES BE FOLLOWING THAT SAME
PRACTICE.
YOU KNOW I I WOULD BE ABLE TO TO
SPEAK TO THE SPECIFIC MEAL
PROVISIONS OF OTHER PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICERS AND APOLOGIZE
THAT.
ARE THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
STATE NEARBY IF YOU CAN THE
MAYBE QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
ABOUT HEARING --
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WILL MOVE FORWARD TO CHRISTMAS
CAME EARLY.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENDLESS ASSOCIATION KIRK ON NATO
LEGAL COUNSEL TO THE CAMPAIGN
FOR THE EMERGENCY AMBULANCE
EMPLOYEE SAFETY AND PREPAREDNESS
ACT WELCOME --
MYSTERY KILLER YOU ALSO I KNOW
THAT --
STAFF REACHED OUT TO A AMAR TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TODAY ARE YOU
REPRESENTING A MARK TODAY'S WELL
I'M NOT I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA AMBULANCE ASSOCIATION.
VERY GOOD ARE THANK YOU PLEASE
PRETTY SURE OF MISTER CHAIR AND
MISTER CHAIR --
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK I JUST BRIEFLY OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDS ASSOCIATION OF
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS DID VOTE
TO SUPPORT OF THIS BALLOT
MEASURE AND I THINK YESTERDAY
THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
ANNOUNCED THAT IT HAD --
INDEED THEY'RE QUALIFIED TO BE
ON THE NOVEMBER BALLOT.
BUT OUR ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS
PRIVATE SECTOR.
AYE EMS PERSONNEL THE EMTS AND
PARAMEDICS THAT THE LA O. WAS
TALKING ABOUT OR A OUR EMPLOYEES.
WE CERTAINLY OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS AND IN SOME OF OUR
JURISDICTIONS PARTICULARLY IN
RURAL AREAS A LOT OF MY MEMBER
COMPANIES LIKE TO SAY WE ARE
ACTUALLY THE ONLY.
A RESPOND HERS IN THE END --
QUITE OFTEN.
BECAUSE WHEN INDIVIDUALS AROUND
THE STATE DIAL 911- THESE ARE
THE FOLKS WHO I GET THERE --
TO SERVICE THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
AS THE LA O. NOTED --
OUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE OR SO
PRIVATE AMBULANCE COMPANIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
A RESPOND 275% OR THREE QUARTERS
OF ALL OF THOSE NINE ONE ONE
CALLS THAT COME THROUGH IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
AND THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR TREATING AND
RESPONDING TO THOSE NINE ONE ONE
CALLS WHETHER THEY ARE.
YOU KNOW A SLIP AND FALL WITH A
BROKEN BONE OR OBVIOUSLY
INDIVIDUALS WHO FACE MORE LIFE
THREATENING --
CASES.
WE ALSO I THINK ARE VERY GOOD --
COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
IN THAT WE PROVIDE A TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
UNCOMPENSATED CARE TO
INDIVIDUALS --
WE ALSO PROVIDE THINGS LIKE YOU
KNOW CPR IN TRAINING TO SCHOOLS
AND SENIOR CENTERS AND ELSEWHERE.
SO HOW DID WE GET HERE ALLIES
THE LA OWE INDICATED IN DECEMBER
OF TWENTY SIXTEEN THE AUGUSTA'S
DECISION CAME DOWN.
NOW WHILE AUGUSTA'S DID DEAL
WITH SECURITY GUARDS AT IF YOU
LOOK AT THE WAGE AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THE WAGE ORDERS IN THE STATE.
THEY ALL HAVE THE SAME SORT OF
LANGUAGE.
AND SO OUR INDUSTRY QUICKLY
LOOKED AT IT AND THOUGHT WELL IF
THEY'RE GONNA DO INTERPRET THAT
EXACT SAME LANGUAGE IN OUR WAGE
ORDER AS IN THE OTHER WAGE ORDER
APPLICABLE TO SECURITY GUARDS.
THAT SAYS WE CAN'T CONTACT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHEN THEY ARE ON
BREAK.
THAT COULD HAVE SERIOUS --
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE AMBULANCE
INDUSTRY.
AND SO AS A RESULT WE ACTUALLY
CAME FIRST TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND YOU ON MISTER CHAIRMAN
THURMAN.
OF MIGHT RECALL THAT THERE WERE
TWO MEASURES A YOUR VICE CHAIR --
HEATH FLORA INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION THAT WAS ACTUALLY
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
AMBULANCE ASSOCIATION.
AND OF THE INDIVIDUAL THE
OPPONENTS TO THIS MEASURE THAT
YOU'LL HEAR FROM SHORTLY WITH
THE SPONSORS OF THE SECOND MAJOR.
ASSEMBLYMAN RODRIGUEZ IS AB.
TWO SIXTY THREE AND WE PURSUED
LEGISLATION HAD LEAST INITIALLY
BECAUSE AGAIN WE THOUGHT WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
EVEN WHEN THEY ARE ON A BREAK.
THAT THEY BE A OF THAT WE BE
ABLE TO CONTACT THE WE SIMPLY
CAN'T.
LET ME LET ME POINT SOMETHING
OUT ONLY HOSPITALS.
AND THE AMBULANCE PROVIDERS ARE
REQUIRED BY LAW.
I TREAT EVERYONE.
WHEN SOMEBODY DIALS 911- WE
DON'T ASK HOW CAN YOU PAY FOR
THIS OR ANYTHING ELSE LIKE THAT?
WE RESPOND HOSPITAL ER'S DUE.
TO THE FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO OF US SO ALL
THOSE OTHER LIKE MEDI CAL
PROVIDERS DOCTORS DENNIS.
THEY CAN CHOOSE THEIR PATIENTS
WE CAN'T.
WITH THE HOSPITAL ER THOUGH THEY
GET TO YOU WHEN THEY GET TO YOU
WE BY LAW ARE REQUIRED TO DO SO
WITHIN THE CONTRACTED PERIOD OF
TIME.
SO WE ARE VERY UNIQUE.
AND AS MUCH AS WE WANT TO ENSURE.
THAT ALL OF OUR EMPLOYEES GET
THE BRAKES THAT THEY ARE
ENTITLED.
TO THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE TO BE
INTERRUPTED.
AND SO WE WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH
ASSEMBLYMAN RODRIGUEZ AND THE
SPONSORS OF THAT MEASURE THAT.
WHILE IT PASSED THIS HOUSES NOW
HAS BEEN SITTING THE PAST THREE
QUARTERS OF A YEAR IN THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE --
AFTER PASSING THE SENATE LABOR
COMMITTEE AND THE ISSUE THERE
AND THAT HAS BEEN ALL ALONG IS
THAT WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT OUR
EMPLOYEES GET THEIR BREAK.
IF THEY ARE --
INTERRUPTED.
THEY SHOULD BE RESCHEDULED.
AND IF THEY CAN'T BE RESCHEDULED.
THEN THEY'RE ENTITLED TO THAT
ONE HOUR PENALTY PAY.
THAT'S WHAT EXISTING LAW HAS
BEEN FOR FIFTY PLUS YEARS THAT'S
WHAT IT CONTINUE SHOULD THAT'S
WHAT IT SHOULD CONTINUE TO BE.
NOW THAT IS WHAT WE ATTEMPTED TO
DO LEGISLATIVELY AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT DID NOT COME
TO FRUITION.
IN THE MEANTIME OR DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS.
ISSUED GUIDANCE THAT ESSENTIALLY
SAID THE AUGUSTA'S DECISION IS
APPLICABLE TO EVERYBODY
[inaudible]
WHICH WHETHER I PERSONALLY LIKE
IT OR NOT I THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY A LOGICAL PLACE FOR
THEM TO END UP BECAUSE AGAIN AS
I SAID EARLIER ALL THE WAGE
ORDERS HAVE THE SAME SORT OF
LANGUAGE THAT WAS INTERPRETED.
IN THE AUGUSTA'S DECISION.
I'M JUST A QUOTE FROM THAT
DECISION ONE SENDS DURING
REQUIRED REST PERIODS.
EMPLOYERS MUST RELIEVE THEIR
EMPLOYEES OF ALL DUTIES AND
RELINQUISH ANY CONTROL OVER HOW
EMPLOYEE SPEND THEIR BREAK TIME.
SO AGAIN THAT MEANS RADIOS TWO
WAY COMMUNICATION DEVICES PAGER
CELL PHONES THAT WOULD ALL HAVE
TO BE OFF AND AGAIN.
WHEN WE HAVE TO RESPOND WITHIN
MINUTES GENTLY FIVE TO SEVEN
MINUTES OR CONTRACTED TIME
DEPENDING ON JURISDICTIONS AND
ALL?
WE CAN'T HAVE SOMEBODY WHO CAN'T
BE CONTACTED AND I THINK QUITE
FRANKLY THAT THE MEMBERS OF YOUR
COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
LABOR COMMITTEE WERE VERY
SYMPATHETIC TO THAT POINT.
BUT NONE THE LESS BECAUSE THE
COURT INTERPRETATION OF THIS.
THE APPLICATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AS TO ALL OTHER
INDUSTRIES AND THE FAILURE OF A
LEGISLATIVE FIX LAST YEAR.
DROVE THE PROPONENTS OF THE
SPONSORS OF THE BALLOT MEASURE
TO PROCEED TO THE BALLOT --
AND I THINK THAT IS AN EFFORT TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY.
IS ADEQUATELY INSURED --%
IT'S JUST UNREALISTIC FROM OUR
HUMBLE PERSPECTIVE TO THINK THAT
THAT --
INTERPRETATION WOULD BE
APPLICABLE TO OUR INDUSTRY AGAIN
WHEN SOMEBODY DIALS 911- THEY
EXPECT PROMPT SERVICE AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE CONTRACTED AND
LEGALLY RESPONSIBLE TO DO --
IT DOES HAVE SOME OTHER
PROVISIONS.
BUT IN THE BILL IT HAS THREE
MAIN PROVISIONS FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE AND WHY WE ENDORSED
THE BALLOT MEASURE.
THE FIRST IS TRAINING ANNUALLY
FOR MASS CASUALTY ACTIVITIES.
A ACTIVE SHOOTERS AND OTHER
NATURAL DISASTERS --
HAVING THAT ANNUAL TRAINING IS
IMPORTANT FOR OUR PERSONNEL OF
COURSE IT'S APPROPRIATELY
EMPLOYER PAID.
THE SECOND MAJOR PROVISION IS
EMPLOYERPAID --
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELLNESS A
EDUCATION AND COVERAGE.
UP TO TEN MENTAL HEALTH VISITS
PER YEAR AGAIN EMPLOYER PAID.
AND THEN OF COURSE TO CONTINUE
THE FIVE DECADE PLUS APPROACH --
IN TERMS OF MEAL AND REST BREAKS
WHICH AGAIN.
A THEY SHOULD BE ENTITLED TO WE
WANT OUR EMPLOYEES ENTITLED TO
IT.
AND IF WE HAVE TO INTERRUPT
THOSE MEAL REST BREAKS THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO BE RESCHEDULED
AND IF WE CAN'T THEY SHOULD BE
COMPENSATED TO DO SO UP FOR FOR
US BEING UNABLE TO RESCHEDULE
THEM.
THAT'S WHAT ALWAYS HAS BEEN THE
INDUSTRY PRACTICE AND THAT'S
WHAT IT CONTINUE SHOULD BE.
UP BUT WE HAVE TO TAKE THIS SORT
OF AN EFFORT THAT'S ENCAPSULATED
IN THIS BALLOT MEASURE BECAUSE
AT THIS POINT IF WE CAN ACHIEVE
A LEGISLATIVE FIX.
AND OF THE COURTS OBVIOUSLY VIEW
THIS LANGUAGE IN A CERTAIN WAY
WHICH IS NOT ASCERTAIN IS NOT --
IN PRIVATE --
EMT SERVICE SO WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OTHERWISE I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME --
QUESTION AT THIS TIME --
COMMITTEE NOTES THAT --
SPEAK IT LEAVES A FREQUENT
PARTICIPATOR IN THIS COMMITTEE
AND I'M GLAD TO HAVE TESTIMONY
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER TRIPS
OUT WE WILL HEAR FROM SO NATO.
I I DON'T HAVE MUCH TO ADD OF
THE NON THIS MCKINLEY'S POINTS I
WOULD JUST --
REITERATE THAT IT ARE THIS IS A
CONTINUATION OF A FIFTY YEAR --
INDUSTRY PRACTICE AND THAT THE
MEASURE PROVIDES IN UNIFORM
STATEWIDE STANDARDS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND TRAINING FOR EMTS AND
PARAMEDICS.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE APPRECIATES
BREVITY THANK YOU --
QUICK THANK YOU WILL NOT HEAR
FROM THE OPPONENTS --
WHO ALSO HAVE TEN MINUTES OF THE
COMMITTEE WELCOMES BACK --
JASON BRITTANY WHO HAS BEEN
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE
WELCOME EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
UNITED EMS WORKERS ASKING LOCAL.
FORTY NINE ELEVEN TOM GO TO HELL --
GOTHAM GOT I THINK I TOM THANK
YOU LEGAL COUNSEL TO UNITE EMS
WORKERS ASK ME LOCAL.
FORTY NINE ELEVEN IN JUST WILL
GO GO LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
MANAGER OF FROM ASK ME.
WE ARE READY WHEN YOU AYE SIR
APPRECIATE IT --
AT THANK YOU BOTH CHAIRS
RAVENOUS TODAY THE REST THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF'S SECTARIAN
TEASING PARAMEDICS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OF ALSO A TWENTY FIVE
YEAR PARAMEDIC IN THIS --
COUNTY SANTA CLARA.
I FIND MYSELF IN AN INTERESTING
POSITION TODAY BECAUSE WE'RE
SITTING HERE IN THE OPPOSITION
TABLE BUT YET WE ACTUALLY
FUNDAMENTALLY SUPPORT PORTIONS
OF THIS INITIATIVE.
AND CONCEPTUALLY --
SUPPORT MOST OF THE INITIATIVE
BUT LET'S MAKE NOT NO MISTAKE
ABOUT THIS.
THE PROPONENTS OF THE BILL DID
NOT MENTION THAT THIS IS A
LIABILITY PROTECTION ISSUE.
ON THE CIVIL LITIGATION THAT THE
LA THOSE OFFICE.
REFERENCED IN HIS [inaudible]
THAT TESTIMONY.
LAST YEAR TO SIX THREE WAS A
FILTER.
REMEDY THE ISSUES WITH THE
INDUSTRIAL WAGE ORDER BECAUSE WE
SUPPORT AN ON DUTY MEAL PERIOD
AS WELL.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT OUR INDUSTRY
IS.
THE INDUSTRIAL WAGE ORDER THE IT
JUSTICE RULING.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE TO APPLY TO OUR SEX.
IT LEADS TO SAFETY ISSUES AND
RESPONSE ISSUES AND WE AGREE
WITH THAT.
AS AN AFFECT WE HAD LEGISLATION
AND WE WERE NEGOTIATING. TO DEAL
WITH THOSE ISSUES AND THAT COURT
RULING.
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE NEGOTIATIONS
BROKE DOWN WITH THE AUTHORS OF
THIS INITIATIVE WHEN WE WERE NOT
WILLING TO PROVIDE THEM THE
LIABILITY PROTECTION THAT THEY
WERE SEEKING.
WE ALSO FUNDAMENTALLY AGREE ON
ACTIVE SHOOTER AND AND MASS
CASUALTY TRAINING.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT REALLY IS NON
SUBSTANTIVE IN THIS ISSUE.
AND THIS INITIATIVE.
COUNTY LENDS THROUGH WHAT U.
AUSSIE PROGRAMS FUND MASS
CASUALTY TRAININGS ON A YEARLY
BASIS THAT IS A CONTINUED
PROCESS THAT I PARTICIPATED IN
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER.
THIS INITIATIVE DOES NOT
SPECIFICALLY ADD.
ANYTHING TO THAT PROCESS.
I SAID AS A TECHNICAL COMMITTEE
AUTHOR WITH THE NATIONAL FIRE
PROTECTION ASSOCIATION ON CROSS.
FUNCTIONAL EMERGENCY RESPONSE
MITIGATION FOR ACTIVE SHOOTER
HOSTILE ADVANCE.
THE ARTICLE ON ACTIVE SHOOTERS
IS NOT SPECIFIC IT DOESN'T ADD
ANY DETAILS AS TO WHAT THAT
LEVEL OF TRAINING WILL BE.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THAT THE
TRAINING I GET FROM THE AUTHOR
THE COMPANY THAT I WORK.
FOR WILL BE SUB STANDARD OF THAT
AND SO I APPROVED --
STAND.
SO FUNDAMENTALLY WE AGREE ON A
LOT OF THIS WE AGREE ON THE EAP
STANDARDS WE AGREE ON IMPROVING
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. FOR OUR
PROVIDERS AYE WE WOULD NEVER
STAND THE WAY OF MORE.
I SERVICES FOR THAT.
BUT AGAIN EAP IS A STANDARD.
THAT IS SUB STANDARD TO THAT THE
ISSUES THAT WE FACE.
WE HAVE ISSUES OF Q. CRITICAL
[inaudible]
STRESS OFTENTIMES MY PROVIDERS
GO TO EAP COUNSELORS THEIR
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY COUNSELORS.
WHICH ARE NOT APPROPRIATE FOR
THE PTSD IN THE CRITICAL
INCIDENT STRESS MANAGEMENT
THERAPY THAT WE NEED
[inaudible]
SO AGAIN.
IT'S SUB STANDARD BUT IT IS AN
INCREASE THAT WE WOULD SUPPORT
IN CONCEPT.
BUT AGAIN WE ARE NOT IN A
POSITION TO SUPPORT THE
LIABILITY PROTECTIONS THAT THIS
INITIATIVE SEEKS FOR PRIVATE
PROVIDERS FOR VIOLATING THE WAGE
ORDER WHICH WAS AFFIRMED BY
THAT'S THE COURTS.
AND IT IS OUR INTENT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK THROUGHOUT THE NEXT
COMING YEARS TO CREATE A
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION.
BUT THAT PROCESS BROKE DOWN WHEN
THE LIABILITY PROTECTIONS WERE
NOT GUARANTEED A HIGH BEHALF
DURING THE NEGOTIATE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GOTTA.
ARE.
THANK YOU TO THEIR COMMITTEE
CHAIR IN THE MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
BRIEFLY DISCUSS THE LEGAL
BACKGROUND THAT LED TO THIS
INITIATIVE --
ONE THING I'D LIKE TO START WITH
IS THAT THE A JUSTICE BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT DID NOT
CHANGE THE LAW THESE PRACTICES
HAVE BEEN UNLAWFUL SINCE THEY
WERE INITIATED IT.
IN IT INTERPRETED.
LANGUAGE THAT HAS BEEN IN THESE
WAGE ORDERS FOR DECADES.
AND THE PURPOSE OF THIS
INITIATIVE IS IT'S NOT A PUBLIC
SAFETY MEASURE IT'S A MEASURE TO
FOR AND ARE IN PARTICULAR TO
AVOID LIABILITY THIS IS A MARGIN
ISSUED OF THEIR SPENT OVER THREE
MILLION DOLLARS PER --
SOLICITING SIGNATURES ALREADY.
I DON'T I DON'T BELIEVE THERE OF
ANY OTHER CONTRIBUTORS TO THIS
CAMPAIGN.
NOW AMHERST TO DEFEND THE
NORWEGIAN OUR CASE THAT.
IS THAT THREATENS TO IMPOSE TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
LIABILITY ON THEM.
FOR THERE PRACTICES INVOLVING
REST BREAKS AND MEAL BREAKS OVER
THE COURSE OF A DECADE.
NOW THAT LIABILITY HAS INCREASED
BECAUSE AMHERST LITIGATION
STRATEGY HAS BEEN TO DELAY THAT
CASE FOR A DECADE.
AND IT'S NOW FINALLY APPROACHING
TRIAL IN THE US WE HAVE THE
URGENCY THAT IS RAISED BY THIS
INITIATIVE.
AND IT'S ALSO PRETTY CLEAR THAT
THAT THE POSITION OF THE
PROPONENTS IS FUNDAMENTALLY
INCONSISTENT.
THE THE PRIVATE AND THOSE
INDUSTRIES SPENT A DECADE
ARGUING THAT THEY HAVE NO
OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE OFF DUTY
REST NO BREAKS.
IF THEY HAVE NO OBLIGATION TO DO
SO THEN THERE'S NO PURPOSE TO
THIS INITIATIVE IF THEY DO HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO DO SO THEN THE
INITIATIVE IS MAINLY HERE TO FOR
THEM TO AVOID THEIR OWN
LIABILITY.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT WE
WE DISAGREE WITH THE LA WAS
ANALYSIS OF THE POTENTIAL
MONETARY BENEFIT TO COUNTIES
BECAUSE WE DON'T NECESSARILY
BELIEVE THAT THAT.
CAN BE SUBSTANTIATED IN PRACTICE
WE THINK THAT.
THESE ARE COSTS THAT.
HAVE ALWAYS EXISTED AND WILL
CONTINUE TO EXIST AND THEY AND
THE BASICALLY IF IF AMHERST
CORRECT THAT THEY ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE BREAKS UNDER
THE CURRENT LAW.
THEN THERE WILL BE NO FINANCIAL
IMPACT OF THIS INITIATIVE IT
WILL DO NOTHING.
IF I AM ARE IS CURRENTLY IN
VIOLATION OF THE WAGE ORDERS.
AND THE SECOND PART OF THIS IS
THAT.
THERE IS UP --
SECTION EIGHT EIGHT NINE OF THIS
INITIATIVE CREATES A
PROPORTIONATELY IN A RETROACTIVE
LIABILITY SHIELD.
AND IT'S IT'S QUITE EXPLICIT
ABOUT IT'S IN TOWN IT'S NOT
CLEAR WHETHER THAT WOULD BE
ENFORCEABLE AND IT WOULD BE THE
SOURCE OF LITIGATION.
BUT IF AMHERST CURRENTLY A
VIOLATION OF THE WAGE ORDER AND
THAT RETROACTIVE LIABILITY
SHIELDS ENFORCEABLE. TEN AM ARE
WOULD BENEFIT AM ARE RECEIVABLE
WINDFALL THAT IS ESSENTIALLY
DERIVED FROM THE EARNED WAGES OF
THE EMMAUS WORKERS.
NOW THESE ARE RELATIVELY LOW
PAID WORKERS AND CRITICAL HIGH
STRESS JOBS.
THE USER PEOPLE THAT DESERVE
TIME OFF TO REST AND RECOVER
FROM IT CAN BE VERY STRESSFUL
PROFESSIONS.
AND WE FUNDAMENTALLY AGREE THAT
EMS WORKERS SHOULD RECEIVE
IMPROVE TRAINING AND IMPROVE
MENTAL HEALTH CARE WE SIMPLY
DON'T THINK THAT.
CAMERAS UNILATERAL INITIATIVE IS
THE WAY TO GO ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU I DON'T TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
I THINK YOU --
STROKE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN THURMOND
AND SENATOR LARA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA JOSH WILL GO WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES OF
CHINA TO REHASH ANYTHING THAT MY
COLLEAGUE COLLEAGUES HAVE
COVERED.
I WILL SAY THAT IT'S UNFORTUNATE.
THAT THE PROPONENTS OF THE
MEASURE AND MARK DIDN'T SEE FIT
TO COME A SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THEIR OWN INITIATIVE I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE COVERED THAT THIS IS
REALLY JUST AN ATTEMPT.
A VERY CYNICAL ATTEMPT TO
RELIEVE THEMSELVES OF DECADES OF
LIABILITY --
THE LA O. CALLED IT A LONG
STANDING PRACTICE --
MR MCKEE LEE SAID IT WAS A FIVE
DECADE APPROACH TO THIS PROBLEM
AND WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ISN'T THE NEW COSTS REFERRED TO
BY THE LA JOH.
THESE OF WAGES THAT BEEN STOLEN
FROM EMPLOYEES OVER DECADES AND
SO THE APPROACH THAT THIS IS
GOING TO CREATE SOME NEW COSTS
FOR THE COMPANIES ARE FOR
COUNTIES MISGUIDED BECAUSE THIS
IS REALLY JUST AN ATTEMPT. TO
RELIEVE LIABILITY FOR THESE
COMPANIES FOR NOT PAYING THEIR
EMPLOYEES.
OVER A VERY LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
AND IT THAT'S AN UNFORTUNATE
ASPECT OF THIS AND THEY'RE
TRYING TO HIDE IT BY PROVIDING.
THE SOME BENEFITS --
THAT COULD ARGUE PROVIDED UNDER
CONTRACTS IN THAT WERE PROPOSED
IN LEGISLATION THAT WE GOT FOR
LAST YEAR.
A AND BECAUSE OF THAT WHEN
OPPOSITION.
NOT I WILL ALSO SAY --
THAT WE APPRECIATE THE APPROACH
OF THIS COMMITTEE --
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME A FEW
OF THE QUESTIONS WERE HAPPY
ANSWER.
THANK YOU ARE TRYING TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IF
THERE ARE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
A SEEN NONE --
WE WILL HEAR OF PUBLIC TESTIMONY
IF THERE'S ANY PUBLIC TESTIMONY
ON THE ISSUE THANK YOU --
TO THE WITNESSES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR UMRIGAR
YES YOU ARE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
AGREE WITH --
WITH THEIR OPPONENTS SAID HERE
ARTERIES WERE INVOLVED IN THAT
JUSTICE DECISION AND AGREED THAT
IT WAS NOT A CHANGE IN LAW AND
THAT -- WE
THINK IT'S SIGNIFICANTLY
PROBLEMATIC THAT THESE BALLOT
INITIATIVES ARE TRYING --
TO ALLOW AND THESE EMPLOYERS TO
ESCAPE LIABILITY FOR CLEAR
VIOLATIONS OF THE LAW SO WE ARE
ALSO OPPOSED.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
PERSONS WISHING TO PROVIDE A
PUBLIC TESTIMONY OF PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE PROPOSED MEASURE.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING GIVE PUBLIC
COMMENT --
THIS COMMITTEE THIS JOINT
HEARING --
IS FOR TO HELP MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS --
THAT THERE BE SUCH A HEARING FOR
ANY MEASURE THAT WILL BE ON THE
BALLOT.
AS THIS --
MEASURE APPARENTLY HAS QUALIFIED
IT'LL BE UP TO THE VOTERS EYES
TO THE DIRECTION THAT THIS WILL
TAKE A SEEING NOTHING FROM THE
MEMBERS AND SEE NOTHING FROM
PUBLIC COMMENT.
AT THIS CONCLUDES AT THE HEARING
ON THE BALLOT MEASURE WILL
ADJOURN THE JOINT SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY LABOR [inaudible]
COMMITTEE HERE.
I THINK YOU.
OUT WE INVITE THOSE VIEW WHO ARE
HERE FOR ARE NORMALLY SCHEDULED
TO US ON THE LABOR COMMITTEE --
TO REMAIN WITH US AND OUR WE
WILL CALL AUTHORS AS THEY MAKE
THEMSELVES AVAILABLE